Freddie Steinmark dad trains him pretty
hard he's here every day after his
practice well I know he's exceptionally
dreamy you have to start the car up yeah
no I think you're hi hi hey 20 laps so
tough putt seven seven is perfect he's
perfect
thanks Debbie you're really fast for a
big guy we will not lose this game
I'm singing buddy your size do as much
damage as you do out there matters for
me to get a scholarship I assure you sir
he weighs more than 145 pounds a junior
college well thank you anyway you wanted
to see me coach I made iron mark watch a
season worth of film you got his
attention we got 200 players fighting
for a spot on a 100 man Ross let's go
Oh coach is right about you you pissed
sir football doesn't build character it
eliminates the weak I'm offering you a
scholarship to attend the University of
Texas and play football Olivia the kosis
thought I was too small to play like the
way you attack you'll not regret giving
me a chance give me my hand back now huh
sorry
I can't see me loving nobody but you
signmark took a big hit looks like he
might be hurt you see you kind of had
your limp on the field don't act like
you're not in pain I know you you're all
right fun leg I think we have to have
somebody take a look at it
a couple of possibilities
I promise coach I will not let you down
I want to play in the Copper Bowl there
is nothing my boy
my boys never back down against nothing
or nobody and you won't now gonna need
all whatever you're going through I am
going through can you hold up one more
game whatever it is you will meet the
challenge